the man who made it all happen uh the
executive in charge
and also a champion uh cody rhodes here
on the rich eisen show how are you cody
oh i am uh i'm doing great it's real
exciting to be
revisiting the conversation uh right
because you you guys were really the
first uh
first big platform that that gave us
that opportunity to talk about dynamite
coming tnt
and now it's been a blessed year in a in
a wild way
so here we are for year two because
people said to you what the hell are you
doing right
didn't they do that didn't they say that
to you tony people still
people still say what the hell are you
doing well i mean
the established wrestling world is they
were you know wwe was unopposed for for
two decades and they've been around 40
years so it definitely
is very uh the challenger brand that we
are it's a limited space and we were
able to grow or
grow right out of it because i i hear
that a lot cody
even to today you know when uh espn and
i parted ways in 2003
and i uh was the the first host and to
this day i'm
i'm thrilled to be still part of nfl
network uh i still hear like you know
what were you thinking back then you
know obviously it's worked out but what
were you thinking
i i hear that to this day so i'm not
surprised that people still say that but
i mean
you made the right decision you gotta
bet on yourself that's what you did now
it's your show it's your it's your house
so you have to bet on yourself
no i know that uh but if i could make
myself also win the championships i
would do that too
it's not exactly
it's such a it's such a pretty belt too
i wish i could show
you in studio it's such a it's such a
pretty belt
i'm sure it is but again uh what if i
had told you
when you did uh come by here um
over a year ago that this is the way it
would be right now
in october of 2020 what would you have
said
if i told you that on that day when you
were here
i'm very uh i'm a confident person but
out of the fold of the individuals that
made this happen i was probably
the most i guess realistic is what i
thought at the time
i would have said i i'm not
shocked i would have been very
pleasantly
surprised it's not that i wasn't
confident
it's just that if we look at where we
truly are last week
uh women 18 to 34 that was the first
time ever that demographic
topped our mail graphic at points during
the show
itv in the uk we're we're doing
extremely well they're including better
than
monday night raw smackdown i mean we're
blowing the competition away there
and we're dominating the wrestling space
on wednesday night it was always going
to be difficult
us being opposed but to dominate in the
fashion we have and i don't mean that
with any bravado i'm just genuinely
really proud of it
um so i would have i would have been
pleasantly surprised so why do you think
it is working cody rhodes why do you
think it's worked the way
it has to what you owe it
authenticity um that's really it when i
get around
individuals sometimes like the warner
media marketing team
are new people to wrestling and they
want to know what makes us different
that's the number one thing i'll say and
what i really
like to extrapolate just on authenticity
for a wrestler
it's it's these characters back in the
80s and 70s when
wrestling fans were rabid for wrestling
you'll hear people say all the time well
it's because they thought it was
they thought it was real it was the
suspension of disbelief
and i i disagree especially if you look
at some of the silly stuff ric flair
and dusty and hulk were doing i actually
think it was the connection made to the
characters and the only way you can
reach across the barricade
and actually connect in a way they want
to see you win or they have root for you
to lose
is being authentic in your interview
authentic in your
ring work and that's what i think we
have that separates us from everybody
well my kids
are watching it a lot cody and uh they
are they are
they're locked in i mean the
authenticity certainly hits and
obviously you need to have kids
you know i've got you got to have kids
that are sitting there watching
um you know and and their viewing habits
are
are you know like american ninja warrior
and things of that nature
and so to watch this as well um
this is this is exactly the type of
thing you're looking for
i imagine as well that's just my kids
how old are your kids
12 nine and seven sir
oh what a good what a good just
cross section that's that's so that's
really great to hear
that as as as for me on
on tv i often i feel like sometimes i'm
a little bit of the last of a dying
breed i'm a really just
kind of white bread good guy the only
way to put it
okay and i like hearing that you know
kids are watching the show because my
biggest fan base is is
excuse excuse young and i like that i
yeah i like that being on tv still in
wrestling well they
they've they've sought it out and then
on occasion you know after some of the
nba playoff games they would run
they would run your programming as well
on tnt
so um you know they're constantly it's
it's on
it's on the screen quite a bit um you
know and so
um i haven't used the dad points yet to
say i i know you
um not yet i haven't busted that out i'm
i'm waiting on that
code yeah you got it in the pocket it'll
it's it's there when you need it if they
get
more into it and more into it bam you
slam that thing down
you're just the coolest i'm just waiting
for you to be unmasked in the mass
singer one time and
then it'll just be a double whammy if
that ever happens you know
oh man that's almost too much the world
is not enough
[Laughter]
all right so i give you the floor on
what this anniversary episode is all
about
cody tell me tell everybody anniversary
anniversary for aw it's one year
of dynamite and we're doing something
very special in a sense that
all the titles uh will be on the line
all all the gold and it's so rare and
wrestling
so you've got a great women's
championship match with cheetah
versus big swole the world championship
on the line john moxley versus
lance archer myself defending the
prettiest belt in the business
tnt championship in a total mismatch
orange cassidy is
is outsized and outgunned but
uh all the respect in the world for him
uh
plus it's an anniversary show that's got
to be filled with all the bells and
whistles and all the surprises
of great american wrestling well i mean
if we're on the subject of total
mismatches how's your wife doing
cody
um he is really leaning into
being the boss of the family yes i'm
sure
well you know every successful venture
needs a brilliant michigan mind behind
it cody
so um you know that's just my two cents
on the subject
really proud of i always told people
she's a michigan grad you know because
i'm this dumb wrestler who didn't go to
college
but she's like really she throws that
out there often in meetings
i'm like like a dummy so i feel like
that's what i'm saying she's really
leaning into being this this boss
yeah this kind of queen thing going on i
don't hey i don't
what can i do i'm in i love her right
you're a lucky man sir with a a
brilliant mind uh in
in inside your family like that with
your wife it's fantastic in the business
that's going on tj
would you like to ask a question of cody
rhodes you're the rich eisen show
wrestling
expert as you know so go forward uh go
for it tj you have the floor
what's up cody how you doing bro i'm
good how are you
i'm great man um you know when you were
here last year
last september you and i talked a little
bit about you know
getting aew started up and you know you
spoke about authenticity
and i shared the story with you about me
and my grandfather wrestling was our
thing
and uh watching your dad the american
dream dusty rhodes
would drive my grandfather crazy when
dusty would get you know
jumped by the four horsemen because he
couldn't understand why dusty didn't get
magnum and nikita and
wait for ric flair in a parking lot or a
gas station and beat him up
and even as a young man i was like well
grandpa i don't think that's how that
works
but yeah the authenticity you talked
about was very real
um you know we had stone cold in here i
asked him this so i'll ask you
martians are coming to invade the earth
cody and you've got to assemble
a survivor series team of four wrestlers
to protect us
all old school guys who would you pick
to uh have on your survivor series
very interesting and you're going
traditional so four
plus me teams of five strive to survive
that thing
yes well you know i asked stone cold and
he didn't put himself on
he said he'd be the coach so you can
either be on it or not but
who would you assemble i i'm maybe
breaking steve's rules here but it's
teams of five striving to survive
uh i would i'd have to uh
i'd have to really hmm such a great
question i'd go
i'd go for sure with mr brodie lee the
man who i just defeated for the tnt
championship
because he's got the size uh and he's
next
he's a modern modern super heavyweight
and how he moves
um in addition to that i throw my
brother in there my
my lovely 50 year old somehow younger
brother i don't know how that dynamic
has been created but
uh i'd put him in there still one of the
best in the world
still absolutely it's just timeless it
pisses me off
um and then i get two more
uh this is this is where it gets tricky
the rubber
is meeting the road here you know what
i'd go
with uh miro who just joined us at aew
after uh having a wonderful run at wwe
he uh
crossed the line and came over because
miro is just oh man
total stuff a lot of heavy weights here
so we got some mirror
uh light heavyweight who could it be
tricky tricky you know what
i'm gonna i'm gonna take a name out of
i'm gonna say rey mysterio i'm gonna say
ray
and it's probably inappropriate for me
to say ray but ray was
he gave me my first big break in
wrestling and he's you need to balance
out all those big boys with a ray
i love that i love that how would you
rate the answer because i
all i heard was supportive family and
his own business venture so you tell me
how that was wrestling-wise
he's got some monsters on this team i'm
gonna tell you that
and you know i don't know if ray can
make that switch over but if he can
that's a great team
i mean this was this was hypothetical
and you said these are these are
martians coming yes
yes yeah sure no i understand um
the trick when you put a super team
together is and i didn't do it with this
though but whenever you're doing
wrestling you also have to pick someone
who will
lose just in case you guys have to lose
the match in this case we didn't pick
anybody who's taking the fall so that
means we got to win this then cody
yeah we gotta win unless dustin gets
beat
[Laughter]
well done cody man hey good uh
good uh good chat as always always love
having you on congratulations again
on your your venture now uh if you need
because i saw
uh again your with your your competition
uh they reached out to mcafee
if you need a sports talk radio host
slash
television uh person to
suit up and go top rope or something uh
uh
you know i can i can dye it for a bit
you know i i can be that guy if you if
you're going in that direction
oh i have i have no doubt that you could
whip pat's ass so you're always my first
always you were the first big spotlight
for us so
you're my you're my tag partner when
you're ready for the match i got it
i got it we can we can have a you know
at least we the love of punting and
wrestling
cody thanks again for the call
appreciate it congrats best of your
family best to your venture
and uh let's keep chatting down the line
yes sir thank you guys so much
you got it that is the executive vice
president and two-time
champion two-time of aew in advance of
aew dynamite anniversary edition
tomorrow
8pm eastern on tnt and that build is
beautiful
indeed hey you watched all the way to
the end thanks for that
watch more right here